take a bit of a look at yourself and
think about what's not so good that you
could improve
that you should improve by your own
standards and that you would improve
you know and set yourself a little goal
um you know maybe you're not studying at
all at
your university or maybe you're maybe
you're at work and you've got this stack
of paper there you know and you haven't
looked at that damn stack for like a
month and you know that you should be
and you're
bothering yourself at night because
you're avoiding that it's like maybe
think i've avoided that stack of paper
completely for one month i'm quite a
coward when it comes to whatever snakes
might be hidden in that stack of paper
how about tomorrow i just like put that
stack of paper in front of me on my desk
and i
like
i glance through it for
15 seconds
see if i can do that
it's like well
you set yourself a goal of improvement
you know it's a humble goal because
really are you such a coward that the
best that you can bloody well manage
after a month of avoidance is 15 seconds
of exposure to a stack of paper you know
it could easily be you've been avoiding
it you're obviously afraid of it and so
the situation could be that dismal and
dire
and you might think well
geez it's no
bomb to my ego it's no
it's it's no it's not fostering the the
strength of my ego to
recognizing myself someone who could
only withstand 15 seconds of exposure to
that thing i'm afraid of and so that's a
form of humility too it's like
there's things you could do to improve
and you know what they are
and there's small steps that you could
take that you might take that would put
you in that direction and then the
question is are you big enough to take
those small steps you know are you
capable of grappling with the fact that
you're fundamentally flawed to the point
where you have to break things down into
almost childlike steps in order to
manage them an answer to that is yeah
you are
and that's the lot of
i don't know if it's a lot of everyone
most people have things they avoid you
know and they're afraid of so i would
say to some degree it's the lord of
everyone
people vary in the degree to which
they've conquered that and you do meet
people from time to time who are
extraordinarily disciplined but most of
the time they've got disciplined in
exactly this manner it's through slow
incremental improvement and then you
challenge yourself it's like well could
i do this that would be
better then you find out and then you
think well is there something slightly
larger and more challenging that i could
do that would be better
and and you try it and you find out and
as you try it and you find out generally
you get better at it and you can take on
larger and larger challenges the only
thing you're missing is momentum you've
got
great ideas great ideas that can change
maybe the world but certainly change
your life your family's life the people
around you your customers great ideas
you're doing things for the right reason
you want to serve you want to help and
you want to make a lot of money you've
got it in you you have the potential
sitting here right in front of you
the only thing you're missing momentum
momentum momentum we need mo momentum
it's not happening because you're not
staying consistent enough on the
momentum
it's it's i think one of the biggest
problems that entrepreneurs face
it's not a lack of ideas it's a lack of
execution consistent execution
getting started and then consistent
execution
and it's why i spend so much time
helping
at least attempting to help
entrepreneurs believe in themselves more
because that gives you the courage the
permission the optimism to go and
actually take the steps
i was talking to a mastermind group last
night
it's a pretty high level group of people
who you know was invited to be their
keynote speaker or special guest i guess
for the month and we were talking about
youtube and getting started on youtube
and why
youtube
this year i think is the number one
strategy that if you are a thought
leader an expert
you have to go in on youtube you'll get
incredible results for your business
and so i was explaining it and people
are like nodding and like yeah yeah it's
like okay but what's the problem like
why are you not going to make a video
the problem is people are too concerned
about it being perfect
well what camera do i use and what
microphone do i use and what lighting do
i use and guys i'm sitting here in my
car
on my phone
with no you know whatever light
the the sun making videos well my wife
is shopping at costco right
can you see the can you see the costco
sign there it is costco
here at costco nina's shopping i'm
making videos let's go
how long have i i've been doing this for
since april 2009
and i'll still make videos it's not that
i disrespect the fancy gear and
everything else but if you're a thought
leader what matters is you teach people
to think like you think and we get so
caught up on things being perfect having
that perfect first step that we don't do
anything at all that's the problem
you're so worried about having the
perfect first step that you don't do
anything at all
meanwhile your dream
slowly dies inside you
because you're not feeding it you're not
giving it oxygen you're not giving it
any kind of momentum
thinking about it alone isn't enough
thinking about it alone it might even be
a form of torture because you know
you're capable of more you know that you
could do it you know it's a great idea
and yet you don't do enough consistent
action on it to actually ever realize it
meanwhile you see somebody else there's
somebody else out there
with less
intent with less heart with less passion
with less purpose than you winning off
of your idea because they just did
something because they're out doing it
imperfectly and you're worried about
getting the perfect first step
i tell the story of me losing a 40
million deal in my 20s because i was
trying to be too perfect i'm still a
recovering perfectionist
i would love everything to be perfect
fully recognizing that that's never
going to happen but having
a release schedule forces me to make
stuff
videos have to go up today
a video has to go up today it has to so
i have to record it
is it
if it's an ideal setting great and if
it's not an ideal setting great
i filmed a video recently going through
a car wash
because a video had to get recorded
and i hope the audio came out well
enough you guys listen to and i'm not
delaying let's go let's let's great
let's go make a video as we drive to a
car wash
that's gonna happen
because no matter how much of a perfect
plan you think you're trying to make at
the beginning as soon as you go out and
start to do it you realize that your
planning wasn't perfect at all
you just don't know enough to make a
perfect plan
it's a problem you don't know enough to
make a perfect plan
and if you're thinking about you know
back to youtube videos you're going to
make youtube videos but you're not going
to start to get the lights and the gear
and the camera and everything else and
learn how to edit and what programs to
use
nothing matters more than recording
and putting up a video
you want to do that other stuff in your
spare time great
but you do that after you actually
record a video and post it
and then tomorrow record another video
and post it and then the next day record
another video and post it with no
editing just put it up
and then you slowly get better at doing
the thing because momentum
is the missing ingredient
so how do we make this practical how do
we take your idea and turn it into
something tangible real something you
can take action on today a couple ideas
for you
the first is what i call the two percent
difference
the two percent difference the two
percent difference is you've got this
big giant idea which is great i love it
i mean the big mission the big goal is
the thing that keeps you motivated
inspired ready to go to work happy about
your life right like where you're going
you need that big mission and
you have to figure out what's the first
two percent
if your goal back to youtube is to is to
have a youtube channel that's successful
and drives traffic and revenue and
impact for you great
what's what's the first two percent of
action not research researching a video
camera is not two percent action
the first two percent is making your
first video
is it perfect no but it's the first two
percent
stop trying to get 100 before you start
two percent the first two percent
go make create whatever that is for you
and your business and your in your goals
you've got a health goal
how much time do you spend researching
the perfect diet researching the perfect
fitness plan researching and then never
doing like
researching how to do squats and
push-ups will not help you until you
actually do a push-up
the first two percent
is to go and do as many push-ups as you
can can you do four push-ups great do
four push-ups
will those four push-ups lead to massive
results for you not physically but
mentally yes
because you did something because you've
proven to yourself that you are an
action taker that you do something you
you build momentum towards the goal and
then tomorrow you do another four
push-ups and the next day you do six
push-ups and the next day maybe you can
do seven push-ups and all of those
little wins stack that momentum stacks
it builds up
so find the first two percent
okay it's super super important and take
some kind of action on it we don't give
ourselves credit for reading watch this
video doesn't count reading doesn't
count listen to a podcast doesn't count
researching doesn't count action doing
something
the two percent difference
the second thing that i give advice on
to help you is
expect to suck at the beginning
expect to suck expect it to suck
and
when you first try something
you don't expect to be great
but you usually don't expect to suck as
bad as you suck
in your head you might be thinking okay
i can do 10 push-ups i'm not going to be
able to do 100 push-ups i'm not going to
be arnold schwarzenegger or whoever i'm
not going to do that many but i can do
at least ten
and then you do it and you do four
you don't expect to suck as badly as you
actually suck right again not suck as a
human just you don't have the skill set
yet or develop the muscles yet
when you make a youtube video you don't
expect to be great you don't expect to
be tony robbins on your first video
but when you record it and then you
watch it back you don't expect to be as
bad as you were
right you watch your back oh my god i
didn't expect to be great but holy cow i
didn't expect to be this bad either
right
and then that kills momentum that sucks
the air out of it that if you have the
expectations of being
not a hundred but being a 10 and you
come in at a four you don't ever get
back and do it again you don't make
another video you don't do another
push-up you don't take the next step
because you expect it to be better than
you were
what you need to recognize is
your first attempt at something is going
to be the worst that video you just made
those push-ups you just did will be the
worst ones that you ever do
and that if you keep going you're going
to get better tomorrow's video will be a
little better and the next video will be
a little bit better your push-ups will
get a little bit better every time right
by taking the action you get a little
bit better through the process so the
one that you recorded today the thing
you did right now the first two percent
will be the worst that you ever do
so don't quit on the worst try you get
up and you do it again get a little bit
better tomorrow so that's why i say
expect to suck expect it to be brutal
expected like the fact that you pressed
record and you said anything at all and
then vomit on your phone is a win
right expect to suck and again it
doesn't mean that i expect to suck as a
person you just don't have the skill set
yet
and how do you develop the skill set by
by practicing by doing the work by
making another video right
and then the third thing is to tie your
self-esteem yourself forth your
self-belief to the effort
we tend to tie our self-worth to the
result how good of a project did i
get the how many push-ups that i do if i
didn't do 10 i feel like a loser right
instead you tie yourself worth to the
effort if you can really embrace those
three things you'll start to
build massive momentum towards your
goals
number one
the two percent difference what's the
smallest possible way for you to get
started towards your goal number two
expect to suck inspect the first version
of whatever you're doing to just be
absolutely terrible
it's amazing it's the best
and then number three tie yourself worth
your self-love your self-belief to the
effort that you're putting in every
single day do those three things
finally build some momentum towards the
goals the mission the dream that you
have because
your dream is worthy of it
your goals are worthy of it you as a
human are worthy of it you've got this
thing that you know you're capable of
more that you know you want to breathe
into the world that's going to serve and
help and contribute and build the life
for you and your family that you want
it's all possible
but not without momentum
do those three things today tomorrow the
next day and it will change your life
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
one of the things i've been talking to
my audiences about is
the relationship between responsibility
and meaning which is
what would you say it's a it's a
constant refrain in the book it's one of
its underlying
messages let's say or
themes is a better way of thinking about
it
you know if you start with the
presumption
that there's a baseline of suffering in
life and that that can be
exaggerated by as a consequence of human
failing as a consequence of malevolence
and betrayal and self-betrayal and
deceit and all those things that we do
to each other and ourselves that we know
that aren't good that amplifies the
suffering that's sort of the baseline
against which you have to work
and and and it's contemplation of that
often that makes people hopeless and
depressed and anxious and overwhelmed
and all of that and and they have the
reasons
but you need something to put
up against that
and what you put up against that is
meaning meaning is actually the instinct
that helps you guide yourself through
that catastrophe and most of that
meaning is to be found
in the adoption of responsibility
so if you think for example if you think
about the people that you admire well
you think about when you have a clear
conscience first because that's a good
thing to aim at which is something
different than happiness right
um a clear consciousness is different
than happiness that's better yeah that's
better you're guilting yourself you're
not feeling bad about yourself that's
right you feel that you've justified
you've justified your existence right
and so you're not waking up at three in
the morning in a cold sweat thinking
about all the terrible things that
you've involved yourself in what you
said to someone that you shouldn't have
said or how you acted or what
opportunity you lost or or or yeah or
or the things that you've that you've
let go that you should have capitalized
on and all of that and so if you think
about the times when you're at peace
with yourself with regards to how you're
conducting yourself in the world it's
almost always conditions under which
you've adopted responsibility right at
least the most the most guilt i think
that you can experience perhaps
is
the sure knowledge that you're not even
taking care of yourself so that you're
leaving that responsibility to other
people because that's pretty pathetic
and i unless you're psychopathic and you
know and you're living a parasitical
life and that that characterizes a very
small minority of people and an even
smaller minority think that's
justifiable but most of the time you're
in guilt and shame because you're not
you're you're not
not only are you not taking care of
yourself let's say so someone else has
to but you're not living up to your full
potential and so there's a existential
weight that goes along with that the
baboon here who's supposed to be
basically just a fool when the story was
first written he turned into what's
essentially a shaman across time and so
he represents the self from the union
perspective now the self is everything
you could be across time so imagine that
there's you and there's the potential
inside you whatever that is you know and
potential is an interesting idea because
it represents something that isn't yet
real yet we act like it's real because
people will say to you you should live
up to your potential and that potential
is partly what you could be if you
interacted with the world in a manner
that would gain you the most information
right because you build yourself out of
the information in the piagetian sense
but it's deeper than that too because we
know that if you take yourself and you
put yourself in a new environment new
genes turn on in your nervous system
they encode for new proteins and so
you're full of biological potential that
won't be realized unless you move
yourself around in the world into
different challenging circumstances and
that'll turn on different circuits so
it's not merely that you're
incorporating information from the
outside world in the constructivist
sense it's that by exposing yourself to
different environments you put different
physiological demands on on yourself all
the way down to the genetic level and
that manifests new elements of you and
so one of the things that happens to
people and this is a very common
cultural notion is that you should go on
a pilgrimage at some point to somewhere
central and that would be say like the
rock in the pride rock and the lion king
because you take yourself out of your
dopey little village and that's just the
little bounded you that everyone knows
and that isn't very expanded and then
you go somewhere dark and dangerous to
the central place and while you do that
you have adventures and they toughen you
and pull more out of you like partly
because you're becoming informed which
means in formation it means you're
becoming more organized at every level
of analysis but there's also more of you
too tell your kid
here's an impossible thing why don't you
go out and fail
you say here's something worth going
after here's a step you could take that
would push you beyond where you are
but that you also have a reasonably high
probability of succeeding at right they
call that within a time frame within
some time frame that's the other thing
you have to parameterize it with regards
to time frame that's right and that puts
you in the zone of proximal development
and that's a that's a concept that was
generated by a guy named vygotsky he was
a russian developmental psychologist and
a smart one it's where the idea of the
zone comes from to be in the zone and
when you're in the zone you're expanding
your skills
at in a manner that's intrinsically
rewarding because you're succeeding and
so you want to set if you're good to
yourself you think okay i need to set a
goal but i need to set a goal that
someone as stupid and useless as me
could probably attain if they put some
effort into it and then you got then
you've got it perfectly because it's not
so high that it's grandiose or
impossible that you fail necessarily and
then justify your bitterness it's like
well i couldn't do well because that
happens to people happens all the time
yeah it's like this all the time you
know it's like it's yes exactly well i
set a goal and i didn't attain it so i'm
not going to set any more goals right
it's like no you set a goal that was
inappropriate for the time frame
that's right you didn't calibrate it
properly and and you're playing a trick
on yourself because you wanted to fail
so that you could justify not having to
try that's why being a victim yeah which
is helpful you're still going to be a
victim it's like there's no way out of
that man so you know because life is
this life is a challenge that in some
sense can't be surmounted so there's no
way out of your problem but there are
certainly proper ways of dealing with it
yeah if you concentrate solely on your
career
you can get a long way in your career
and i would say that that's a strategy
that a minority of men preferentially do
that that's all they do they work like
70 80 hours a week they go flat out on
their career they're staking everything
on the small probability of exceptional
status in a narrow domain but it's it's
hard on them they don't have a life it's
very difficult for them to have a family
they don't know how to take any leisure
activity like they get very
one-dimensional now it may be that that
unit dimensionality is the price you
have to pay to be exceptional at one
thing right because if you're going to
be something like a genius level
mathematician and you want to do that
for or a scientist say it's like you're
in your lab you're in your lab all the
time you're working 70 hours a week or
80 hours a week you're smart you're
dedicated you're uni-dimensional and
that's how you get to beat all the other
people who are doing that it's the only
way but the problem is you don't get a
life now if you love being a scientist
and you have that kind of
focus of mind well first of all you're a
rare person and second you're going to
pay for it but fine more power to you
but
but
it's a
it's a risky business to do that you
sacrifice a lot for it you know and i
would say
most often if you're speaking about
having a healthy life that isn't what
you do
you spread yourself out more so you know
you have a family you have some things
that you do outside of work that are
meaningful to you and useful
you you have a network of friends
um well that those three things alone
are
four things alone or plenty to keep you
well oriented and then if one of those
things collapses
you know everything doesn't go now the
the price you pay for that is the more
you strive to optimize that balance the
less likely you are to be fantastically
successful at any single one of them but
you might have a very you know if you
can consider your life as a whole
that might be a winning strategy take a
bit of a look at yourself and think
about what's not so good that you could
improve
that you should improve by your own
standards and that you would improve
you know and set yourself a little goal
um you know maybe you're not studying at
all at
your university or maybe you're maybe
you're at work and you've got this stack
of paper there you know and you haven't
looked at that damn stack for like a
month and you know that you should be
and you're boy bothering yourself at
night because you're avoiding that it's
like maybe
think i've avoided that stack of paper
completely for one month i'm quite a
coward when it comes to whatever snakes
might be hidden in that stack of paper
how about tomorrow i just like put that
stack of paper in front of me on my desk
and i
like
i glanced through it for
15 seconds
see if i can do that
it's like well
you set yourself a goal of improvement
you know it's a humble goal because
really are you such a coward that the
best that you can bloody well manage
after a month of avoidance is 15 seconds
of exposure to a stack of paper you know
it could easily be you've been avoiding
it you're obviously afraid of it and so
the situation could be that dismal and
dire
and you might think well
geez it's no
bomb to my ego it's no
it's it's no it's not fostering the
strength of my ego to
recognize myself someone who could only
withstand 15 seconds of exposure to that
thing i'm afraid of and so that's a form
of humility too it's like
there's things you could do to improve
and you know what they are
and there's small steps that you could
take that you might take that would put
you in that direction and then the
question is are you big enough to take
those small steps you know are you
capable of
grappling with the fact that you're
fundamentally flawed to the point where
you have to break things down into
almost child-like steps in order to
manage them an answer to that is yeah
you are
and that's the lot of
i don't know if it's a lot of everyone
most people have things they avoid you
know and they're afraid of so i would
say to some degree it's the law of
everyone
people vary in the degree to which
they've conquered that and you do meet
people from time to time who are
extraordinarily disciplined but most of
the time they've got disciplined in
exactly this manner it's through slow
incremental improvement and then you
challenge yourself it's like well could
i do this that would be better
then you find out and then you think
well is there something slightly larger
and more challenging that i could do
that would be better
and and you try it and you find out and
as you try it and you find out generally
you get better at it and you can take on
larger and larger challenges the best
thing you can do is teach people to
write because there's no difference
between that and thinking and one of the
things that just blows me away about
universities is that
no one ever tells students why they
should write something it's like well
you have to do this assignment
well why are you writing well you need
the grade it's like no
you need to learn to think
because thinking makes you act
effectively in the world thinking makes
you win the battles you undertake and
those could be battles for good things
if you can think and speak and write you
are absolutely
deadly
nothing can get in your way
so that's why you learn to write it's
like
and i can't believe that people aren't
just told that it's it's it's like
it's the most powerful weapon you can
possibly provide someone with and i mean
i know lots of people who've been
staggeringly successful and watch them
throughout my life i mean those people
you don't want to have an argument with
them they'll just slash you into pieces
and they're not in a malevolent way it's
like if you're going to make your point
and they're going to make their point
you better have your points
organized because otherwise you're going
to look
like and be an absolute idiot you are
not going to get anywhere and if you can
formulate your arguments coherently and
make a presentation if you can speak to
people if you can lay out a proposal god
people give you money they give you
opportunities you have influence if
you're harmless you're not virtuous
you're just harmless
you're like a rabbit
a rabbit isn't virtuous
it's just you just can't do anything
except get eaten it's not virtuous
if you're a monster and you don't
act monstrously
then you're virtuous but you also have
to be a monster well you see this all
the time harry potter is like that too
it's like he's he's flawed he's hurt
he's got evil in him he can talk to
snakes man he breaks rules all the time
all the time he's not obedient at all
but you know he has a good reason for
breaking the rules and if if he couldn't
break the rules him and his little
clique of rule breaking you know
troublemakers if they didn't break the
rules
they wouldn't attain the highest goal
so it's very peculiar but it's it's very
very it's a very very very very common
mythological notion you know the hero
has to be
the hero has to be a monster
but a controlled monster batman is like
that you know i mean it's it's
everywhere it's it's the story you
always hear you have to be
humble and wise enough to understand
that you might have to aim pretty damn
low especially in those places where
you're not functioning well
and it might be so embarrassing that you
can't
even that you can't bring yourself to
fathom that that's actually who you are
but you know
jung described the fool
the archetypal figure of the trickster
and the fool as the precursor to the
savior to the redeemer and that's
unbelievable bit of wisdom because
what you meant was that
to put yourself together which is to
follow the path of redemption
to follow the redeemer
if the redeemer is a type of personality
that you could in fact be inhabited by
or manifest
then this first step towards that is to
allow yourself to be a fool
right
it's because
you you don't know what you're doing
you have to admit that and there's going
to be a loss of ego or destruction of
ego arrogant ego that necessarily
accompanies that but you need the loss
of that arrogant ego because it's
precisely what's interfering with your
movement forward you know it's part of
the adversarial process mythologically
speaking that stops moral progress
you're too proud of who you think you
are to notice what you're like so that
you could change properly you don't want
to sacrifice that part of yourself it's
probably associated with some delusion
that
helps you maintain in
what you say a positive although very
fragile self-image you know in the
absence of genuine effort when i was 25
or so i probably weighed about 138
pounds i smoked like packed cigarettes
day i drank
tremendous amount of alcohol i was from
northern alberta this rough little town
up in northern alberta called fairview
and you know there were long winters
there and my friends were heavy drinkers
and most of them dropped out of school
by the time they were 15 or 16 went off
to work on the oil rigs and you know it
was a rough town and we drank a lot i
started when i was 14 and you know um
and so
i was i had a lot of bad habits let's
say and uh
things that were and i wasn't in great
shape physically and i was also still
intellectually obsessed by as i am now
and uh
so that would have been that would have
been in 85 but when i but i decided
around that about 85 84 something like
that maybe a little earlier that i was
really going to try to get my act
together
and uh
so i started doing that i you know i
first of all i
i quit smoking oh that took a long time
because i eventually had to quit
drinking too in order to quit smoking
and i
started working out starting playing
sports which i'd never done you know i
don't regret that i had a fine time when
i was a kid and but
i needed really to get disciplined i had
to do it because
i was working on these hard problems
that you know that i've been discussing
with all of you and i've been working on
them really you know obsessively since i
was probably about 18 maybe even earlier
than that and got to the point around 25
when i was in graduate school trying to
get my phds doing all my research like i
published 15 papers by the time i
graduated with my phd which was by i
think by a fairly large measure the most
papers that any un graduate student at
that time had ever published at mcgill i
think that's right might have been twice
as many or maybe twice as many maybe
even three times as many and at the same
time i wrote maps of meaning which was a
terrible terrible
terribly difficult thing to do because i
was writing about three hours a day
doing that and i couldn't do all that
and continue with my misbehavior you
know my sort of
my
what would you say my my
my hedonistic
my hedonistic
my massive hedonistic consumption of
alcohol and all of that i just couldn't
keep it up and also work seriously on
the issues that were at hand so
you know i had to stop that's a
sacrifice i had to stop
messing about and straighten myself out
you're actually tougher than you think
you never knew that and maybe you didn't
want to take on the responsibility
because you know people play a role in
their own demise so to speak when you
had opportunity to go out and explore or
withdraw because you were afraid you
chose to withdraw because you were
afraid so it's not only that you were
overprotected often it's that you were
willing to take advantage of the
fact that you were over protected and
run back there whenever you had the
opportunity you know so maybe you're a
kid in the playground right and you're
having some trouble with other kids and
you know in the back of your mind i
should deal this with deal with this
myself but you go and tell your mom and
get her to intervene and you know that
that's not right you know that you're
breaking the social contract but it's
easier and so that's what you do you run
off to an authority figure and hide
behind the great father right roughly
speaking well the problem with that is
you don't learn how to do it yourself so
then you have to relearn it painfully
when you're 40. so then you take people
out
you say well what are you afraid of rank
it from 1 to 10.
so 10 is
make a list of 10 things you're afraid
of the least the thing you're least
afraid of we'll call number 10.
so we'll start with that okay well i'm
afraid of elevators okay well let's
let's look at a picture of an elevator
let's have you imagine
being in an elevator let's go out to an
elevator and let you watch the terrible
jaws of death open because that's how
you're responding to it symbolically
right and you're going to do that at it
at the the closest
proximity you can manage
you find out you go do that it works
you're nervous as hell especially
from an anticipatory perspective shaking
you go out you stop you watch it happen
and you actually calm down you do that
10 times and it no longer bothers you
well what you've learned that you didn't
die but more importantly than that
you've learned that you could withstand
the threat of death that's what you've
learned
and then you move a little closer and
then you move a little closer and then
you move a little closer and finally
you're back in what's no longer the
elevator from a symbolic perspective
it's a tomb right it's it's it's a place
of enclosure and isolation and you learn
turns out i can withstand that
and then you're met much more
together much more confident and that's
often one of the things that often
happens in situations like that i've
seen this multiple times is that
if you run someone through an exposure
training process like that and and
toughen them up they'll often start
standing up to people around them in a
way they never did before you don't have
to necessarily have done anything wrong
for things to get completely out of
control
it's a terrifying doctrine
but it's not a hopeless doctrine because
it still says that there's a way forward
there's a pathway forward and the
pathway forward is to adopt a motive
being that has some nobility
so that you can tolerate yourself and
perhaps even have some respect for
yourself as someone who's capable of
standing up in the face of that terrible
vulnerability and suffering and that the
pathway forward as far as the
existentialists are concerned is by well
certainly by the avoidance of deceit
particularly in language but also by the
adoption of responsibility for the
conditions of existence and some attempt
on your part to actually rectify them
and the thing that's so interesting
about that is that well two as far as
i'm concerned
and some of this is from clinical
experience you know if you take people
and i've told you this and you expose
them voluntarily to things that they are
avoiding and are afraid of you know that
they know they need to overcome in order
to meet their goals their self-defined
goals if you can teach people to stand
up in the face of the things they're
afraid of they get stronger
and you don't know what the upper limits
to that are because you might ask
yourself like if for 10 years if you
didn't avoid doing what you knew you
needed to do by the deaf by your own
definitions right within the value
structure that you've created to the
degree that you've done that what would
you be like
well you know there are remarkable
people who come into the world from time
to time and there are people who do find
out over
decades-long periods what they could be
like if they were who they were if they
said
if they spoke their being forward
and they get stronger and stronger and
stronger and we don't know the limits to
that we do not know the limits to that
and so you could say well in part
perhaps the reason that you're suffering
unbearably can be left at your feet
because you're not everything you could
be and you know it and of course that's
a terrible thing to admit and it's a
terrible thing to consider but there's
real promise in it right because it
means that
perhaps there's another way that you
could look at the world and the number
another way that you could act in the
world so what it would reflect back to
you would be much better than what it
reflects back to you now because you
know my my experience is with people
that we're probably running at about 51
percent of our capacity something i mean
you can think about this yourselves i
often ask undergraduates
how many hours a day you waste or how
many hours a week you waste and the
classic answer is something like four to
six hours a day you know inefficient
studying
watching things on youtube that not only
do you not want to watch that you don't
even care about that make you feel
horrible about watching after you're
done that's probably four hours right
there
you know you think well that's 20 25
hours a week it's 100 hours a month
that's two and a half full work weeks
it's half a year of work weeks per year
and if your time is worth
20 an hour which is a radical
underestimate it's probably more like 50
if you think about it in terms of
deferred wages if you're wasting 20
hours a week you're wasting 50 000 a
year and you are doing that right now
and it's because you're young wasting 50
000 a year is a way bigger catastrophe
than it would be for me to waste it
because i'm not going to last nearly as
long and so if your life isn't
everything it could be you could ask
yourself well what would happen if you
just stopped wasting the opportunities
that are in front of you
you'd be
who knows how much more efficient 10
times more efficient 20 times more
efficient that's the pareto distribution
you have no idea how efficient efficient
people get it's completely it's off the
charts
well and if we all got our act together
collectively and stop making things
worse because that's another thing
people do all the time not only do they
not do what they should to make things
better they actively attempt to make
things worse because they're spiteful or
resentful or arrogant or deceitful or
or homicidal or genocidal or all of
those things all bundled together in an
absolutely pathological package if
people stopped really really trying just
to make things worse we have no idea how
much better they would get just because
of that
so there's this weird dynamic that's
part of the existential system of ideas
between human vulnerability social
judgment
both of which are are
our major causes of suffering and the
failure of individuals to adopt the
responsibility that they know they
should adopt if you concentrate solely
on your career
you can get a long way in your career
and i would say that that's a strategy
that a minority of men preferentially do
that that's all they do they work like
70 80 hours a week they go flat out on
their career they're staking everything
on the small probability of exceptional
status in a narrow domain but it's hard
on them they don't have a life it's very
difficult for them to have a family they
don't know how to take any leisure
activity like they get very
one-dimensional now it may be that that
unit dimensionality is the price you
have to pay to be exceptional at one
thing right because if you're going to
be something like a genius level
mathematician and you want to do that
for or a scientist say it's like you're
in your lab you're in your lab all the
time you're working 70 hours a week or
80 hours a week you're smart you're
dedicated you're uni-dimensional and
that's how you get to beat all the other
people who are doing that it's the only
way but the problem is you don't get a
life now if you love being a scientist
and you have that kind of
focus of mind well first of all you're a
rare person and second you're going to
pay for it but fine more power to you
but
but
it's a
it's a risky business to do that you
sacrifice a lot for it you know and i
would say most often if you're speaking
about having a healthy life that isn't
what you do
you spread yourself out more so you know
you have a family you have some things
that you do outside of work that are
meaningful to you and useful
you you have a network of friends
um well that that those three things
alone are four things alone or plenty to
keep you well oriented and then if one
of those things collapses
you know everything doesn't go
now the the price you pay for that is
the more you strive to optimize that
balance the less likely you are to be
fantastically successful at any single
one of them but you might have a very
you know if you can consider your life
as a whole
that might be a winning strategy stop
doing the things that you know are wrong
that you could stop doing
right so it's a fairly it's a fairly
limited attempt first of all we're not
going to say that you know
what the good is or what the truth is in
any ultimate sense but we will presume
that there are things that you're doing
that for one reason or other you know
are not in your best interests there's
something about them that you just know
you should stop they're kind of
self-evident to you other things you're
going to be doubtful about you're not
going to know
which way is up and which way is down
but there are things that you're doing
that you know you shouldn't do
now some of those you won't stop doing
for whatever reason you don't have the
discipline or maybe there's a secondary
payoff or you don't believe it's
necessary or it's too much of a
sacrifice or you're angry or resentful
or or afraid who knows so forget about
those for now
but there's another subset that you
could stop doing it might be little
thing well that's fine stop doing it
and see what happens and what will
happen is
your vision will clear a little bit
and then something else will pop up in
your field of apprehension that you will
also know you should stop doing and that
you could stop doing because you
strengthened yourself a bit by stopping
doing the particular stupid thing that
you were doing before that just puts you
together a little bit more and you could
do that
repeatedly for for an indefinite period
of time and and
you know that doesn't necessarily mean
that you're going to ever be able to
formulate a clear
and final picture of what constitutes
the truth
and the good but it does mean that
you'll be able to continually move away
from what's untruth and what's bad
and you know that's not a bad start i
had a plumber once you know
it was the night it was the night before
we were putting drywall in our house we
were redoing a house and
he had put in all the plastic piping you
know and i was going to test the joints
they're supposed to be glued together
with this pipe glue right and i said i
told him i had to test the joints and he
said well you don't have to test my
joints they never leak and i thought
yeah that's okay how about if i test
them so i went up on the third floor and
filled the pipes with water tapping them
in the basement like you're supposed to
and like half an hour later i had two
inches of water in the basement there
were 30 leaking joints that was the
night before the drywallers were
supposed to show up so
well so he wasn't particularly competent
that's the point of that story but even
more so he had put a bunch of the
plastic pipe outside
where the drywall would be so it would
have been sticking through the wall so i
spent a frenetic night you know sawing
through plastic pipe and re-gluing
joints so that my well so that the dry
rollers could come in what's the point
if you're going to be a plumber man be a
good plumber because otherwise all you
do is go out there and cause trouble we
don't need people to cause more trouble
we need people to solve problems you
know and so you can be a tradesman and
you can be you can make a lot of money
as a tradesperson it's a bloody reliable
honorable uh forthright productive way
of making a living and there is a hell
of a lot of difference between a working
man who knows what he's doing and one
who doesn't both in terms of skill and
ethics right and you work with someone
who knows what they're doing it's a
bloody pleasure they tell you what
they're going to do they tell you how
much it will cost they go and do it it
works and you pay them perfect
everyone's happy and that's what happens
when you have genuine hierarchies of
competence and so you listen to these
panderers of egalitarianism
egalitarianism and equity and they fail
to recognize completely that there are
differences in rank between people it's
not such a terrible thing man maybe you
wouldn't be a great lawyer like it's
certainly possible most people aren't
but that doesn't mean there isn't
something you could be great at there's
lots of hierarchies to attempt to climb
and if you fail in one
go trying another but the point is
you're still trying to aim for the top
and what the hell are you going to do if
you don't try to aim for the top you
know flap about uselessly and whine
about your life it's not helpful it'll
just make you miserable you're not
reliable to anyone you can't help out in
a crisis it's like so you tell young
people and this is another message for
conservatives like i don't care what
you're going to do but go out there and
make something of yourself for god's
sake be an honest person and work and
get to the top of whatever it is that
you want to get to the top of you know
and and and
and that stand up for yourself like a
respectable human being and be a bit of
a light on the world instead of a blight
you know and you can tell young people
that and they haven't been told that by
anyone now and so the young men are so
hungry for that that it's it's painful
to watch they're so relieved when
someone finally comes up and says hey
you know
you you get your act together a bit
discipline yourself see if you can learn
to tell the truth concentrate on
something for a year or two you could be
a bloody world beater they think really
that's possible wow that would be that
would be interesting that might make
life for life worth living it's like
yeah it might so why don't you go do it
that's what the damn universities were
supposed to be teaching people they've
forgotten that i went to harvard a month
ago month and a half used to teach there
and i talked to a bunch of students you
know and i told them
it's not easy to get into harvard you
know like you're a valedictorian if
you're at harvard and not only are you a
valedictorian you're way better than
most people at at least two other things
or you don't get in and so like it's i
don't know what the acceptance rate is
like five percent and believe me not
everybody applies so it's a very
selective school and so why am i saying
that it's like these are high quality
kids so i told them what i just told you
it's like here you are at harvard it's
like get yourself educated man read some
books learn to talk learn to think make
yourself into something get the hell out
there and make the world that put you
here happy that you were put there in
that great institution you know
and they came up to me afterwards and
said god i wish someone would have told
us that when we were in our first year
it's like jesus why didn't someone tell
them that for god's sake it's supposed
to be the greatest university in the
world is it so difficult to figure that
out we're built for struggle us human
beings
not after
the bubbles of bliss that dostoevsky
described in in notes from underground
we're built to contend with the world
we're built to contend with reality you
want to challenge and the best way that
you can take on a challenge because a
challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure you want to be strong
and you get strong by taking on optimal
challenges and so you lay out your
destiny in the world and you take the
slings and arrows of fate and you make
yourself stronger while you're doing so
and you might fail and fortune might do
you in
but it's your best bet and you know
people have
also people that have extracted
unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures
and so and i'm not saying that in a
naive way i know perfectly well what
happens to people you know you're doing
fine in life and then you get cancer and
then six months later you're dead and
all the heroism in the world isn't going
to save you at that point but that's not
the point
that's not the point life is bounded by
mortality but that doesn't mean that you
don't get out there and contend and you
develop by contending and you minimize
the net amount of suffering in the world
and that's something man that's
something to do before you can be a
painter who can paint what's beyond mere
memory
you you have to inculcate that
discipline skill and a lot of that is
painful repetition and hard grinding
work it's the sacrifice of the present
for the future but once you manage that
then things open up and virtually
everything you learn of value is like
that's very very very difficult to learn
to write and there's arbitrary arbitrary
rules that you have to follow and bind
yourself to and while you're learning
those rules the probability that you
have any creative freedom to speak of or
any facility with the rules is very low
you're you're a rank beginner and and
even to some degree whatever creativity
you have is going to have to be stifled
while you're passing through that that
keyhole
but if you pass through it then
something massive opens up on the other
side and it is definitely the case that
disciplinary institutions universities
are exactly that is their places of
guidance and and they're places to
encourage people to develop the
discipline that's necessary to see
beyond the discipline i mean that's why
we have disciplines right i mean the
words aren't there by accident you have
to narrow yourself first and then you
can broaden outward and so that's and
that's part of the process of maturation
that part of that that's part of the
sacrifice of childhood say
in childhood you're nothing but
potential but it's not realized and you
don't know how to realize it and so then
the question is well how do you get to a
point where you realize the potential
and the answer is you sacrifice almost
all of it to a single direction this is
nietzsche's commentary on the catholic
church he's a great admirer of the
catholic church despite the fact that he
was also a radical
critic critic of christianity said the
cat see the thing about the catholic
church is that it forced
everything to be interpreted within a
single explanatory framework and that
was a discipline
and once that discipline was established
then the disciplined mind could explode
in every direction which is precisely
what happened
and so and and and that's the thing
about growing up is that when you're a
teenager and a young adult you have to
sacrifice everything you could have been
as a child to be the one thing that
you're aiming at but then that opens up
and and the universities are part and
parcel of that process and you need the
guidance because
the
the the library is too large to wander
through it unaided it isn't merely that
your fate depends on whether or not you
get your act together and to what degree
you decide that you're going to live out
your own genuine being it isn't only
your fate it's the fate of everyone that
you're networked with and so you know
you think well
there's nine billion seven billion
people in the world we're going to peak
at about nine billion by the way and
then it'll decline rapidly but seven
billion people in the world and who are
you you're just one little dust mote
among that seven billion and so it
really doesn't matter what you do or
don't do but that's simply not the case
it's the wrong model because you're at
the center of a network you're a node in
a network of course that's even more
true now that we have social media
you'll you'll know a thousand people at
least over the course of your life and
they'll know a thousand people each and
that puts you one person away from a
million and two persons away from a
billion
and so that's how you're connected and
the things you do
they're like dropping a stone in a pond
the ripples move outward and they affect
things in ways that you can't fully
comprehend and it means that the things
that you do and that you don't do are
far more important than you think
and so if you act that way of course the
terror of realizing that is that it
actually starts to matter what you do
and you might say well that's better
than living a meaningless existence it's
better for it to matter but i mean if
you really ask yourself would you be so
sure if you had the choice i can live
with no responsibility whatsoever the
price i pay is that nothing matters
or i can reverse it and everything
matters
but i have to take the responsibility
that's associated with that it's not so
obvious to me that people would take the
meaningful path
you know when you say well nihilists
suffer dreadfully because there's no
meaning in their life and they still
suffer yeah but the advantage is they
have no responsibility
so that's the payoff and i actually
think that's the motivation say well i
can't help being nihilistic all my
belief systems have collapsed it's like
yeah maybe
maybe you've just allowed them to
collapse because it's a hell of a lot
easier than acting them out and the
price you pay is some meaningless
suffering but you can always whine about
that and people will feel sorry for you
and you have the option of taking the
pathway of the martyr so that's a pretty
good deal all things considered
especially when they are
when the alternative is to
bear your burden properly and to live
forthrightly in the world well what
solzhenitsyn figured out and so many
people in the 20th century it's not just
him even though he's the best example is
that
if you live a pathological life you
pathologize your society and if enough
people do that then it's hell
really
really
and you can read the gulag archipelago
if you have the fortitude to do that and
you'll see exactly what hell is like and
then you can decide if that's a place
you'd like to visit
or even more importantly if it's a light
if it's a place you'd like to visit and
take all your family and friends
because that's what happened in the 20th
century you need a value hierarchy
it's inevitable that you have a value
hierarchy and that you look at the world
through it and that it should be well
structured and that there should be
something of divine importance at the
top i would say what should occupy the
top position is
the realization for example that each
person is of divine value and that the
most appropriate way of interacting with
potential is by
embodying and speaking the truth
that's not a bad way of
briefly conceptualizing what might be
at the highest
pinnacle of the value structure i would
say that's what the logos is
and so
the soul
is
a
the soul is what manifests itself in the
choice between different pathways
in in the choice between different ways
of transforming the potential of the
future into the actuality of the present
and it does that
by making ethical decisions by choosing
between good and evil at each choice
point and to the degree that it chooses
good then it takes the raw potential of
the future
and it transforms it into
the being of the present that is good
and to the degree that it
does that in a manner that's evil and
contaminated by malevolence and hatred
and vengefulness then it takes a pathway
that corrupts the world and makes things
worse
and
it's the soul that's doing that and it's
the soul that's responsible for that and
it's also
that active part of the soul that's
shaping
the deeper soul in some sense which
would be something like the cumulative
consequence of all those choices
something akin to what people
more classically have referred to as
character if you configure your life
so that what you are genuinely doing is
aiming at the highest possible good
then the things that you need to
to survive
and to thrive on a day-to-day basis will
deliver themselves to you
that's a hypothesis and it's not some
simple hypothesis right because what it
basically says is if you dare to do the
most difficult thing that you can
conceptualize your life will work out
better than it will if you do anything
else
well how are you going to find out if
that's true well it's a kierkegaardian
leap of faith there's no way you're
going to find out whether or not that's
true unless you do it so no one no one
can tell you either because
just because it works for someone else i
mean that's interesting and all that but
it's no proof that it'll work for you
you have to be all in in this game there
is no more effective way of operating in
the world than to conceptualize the
highest good that you can and then
strive to attain it there's no
more practical pathway
to the kind of success that you could
have if you actually knew what success
was you have to negotiate until you come
to the best solution that can be
negotiated which isn't necessarily a
perfect solution but it might be the
best one that can be done and then you
have to stick with it until the next
negotiation and if you get upset during
the negotiations which you likely will
because these are difficult topics how
to divide up responsibilities in the
house and people get mad because they
feel they've been taken advantage of or
aren't being listened to
one of the rules was well you can leave
the discussion but only until you calm
down and then you have to come back
because these things have to be
pushed through they have to be
negotiated through because the
alternative is well important things
don't get done or people
do them resentfully because they're sort
of forced by their own orderliness or
their own conscientiousness or
or
but we know by force psychological or
otherwise on the part of other people
these things have to be negotiated
through
you can tell if you've got
the balance between making peace and
speaking the truth right if the
conversation continues and it can be
emotional and will be and can be
difficult because important things have
to be dealt with but as long as
the people are still in the conversation
and communicating then you then you've
got the balance right you know and you
might have to take a break
maybe you have to hold off till the next
day
maybe sometimes when you're negotiating
something that's difficult you have to
offer the other person the opportunity
to sleep on their decision too
which i think is often a very good idea
if you have to make an important
decision in your life it's very
useful to tell the person that you're
negotiating with that look i'm
interested in this and it seems good but
i'm not gonna agree until i sleep on it
gives you
well lots of things happen when you
sleep you organize your brain when you
sleep at least to the degree that you
can organize it and you can often be
more solid or more doubtful about a
decision if you sleep on it the world
shifts itself
around your aim
because you're you're a creature that
has a name you have to have a name in
order to do something you're an aiming
creature you look at a point and you
move towards it it's built right into
you
and so you have a name well let's say
your aim is the highest possible aim
well then so that sets up the world
around you it organizes all of your
perceptions it organizes what you see
and you don't see it organizes your
emotions and your motivations
so you organize yourself around that aim
and then what happens is the day
manifests itself as a set of challenges
and problems and if you solve them
properly then you stay on the pathway
towards that ape and you can concentrate
on the on the on the day and so that way
you get to have your cake and eat it too
because you can you can point into the
distance the far distance
and you can live in the day
and it seems to me that that's
that makes every moment of the day
supercharged with meaning that that's
how because if everything that you're
doing every day is related to the
highest possible aim that you can
conceptualize well that's the very
definition of the meaning that would
sustain you in your life adopt the mode
of
authentic being
and that is something like
refusing to participate in
the lie in deception in the lie to
orient your speech as much as you can
towards the truth
and to take responsibility for your own
life and perhaps also for the lives of
other people and there's something about
that that's
meaningful and responsible and noble but
also serves to mitigate the very
suffering that produces
say the nihilism or the flea into the
arms of flea or or the or the
escape into the arms of totalitarians to
begin with
you need something to shelter you
against your own vulnerability i started
to pay very careful attention to what i
was saying
i don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily but i could
feel a sort of split developing in my
psyche and the split and i've actually
had students tell me the same thing has
happened to them
after they've
listened to some of the material that
that i've been describing to all of you
but
i split into two
let's say
and one part was the let's say the old
me that was talking a lot
and that
liked to argue and that liked ideas
and there was another part that was
watching that part like just with its
eyes open
and neutrally judging
and the part that was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going
that isn't your idea
you don't really believe that
you don't really know what you're
talking about
that isn't true and i thought hmm that's
really interesting so now i've and that
was happening to like 95 of what i was
saying and so then i didn't really know
what to do i thought okay this is
strange so maybe i've fragmented and
that's just not a good thing at all i
mean it wasn't like i was hearing voices
or anything like that i mean it wasn't
like that
it was it was well people
have multiple parts
so then i had a this weird conundrum is
like well which of those two things are
me
is it the part that's listening and
saying no that's
rubbish that's a lie that's
you're doing that to impress people
you're just trying to win the argument
you know
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal verbal business me
and i didn't know but i decided i would
go with the critic and then what i
tried to do what i learned to do i think
was to stop saying things that made me
weak
and now that i mean i'm still trying to
do that because i'm always
feeling when i talk
whether or not the words that i'm saying
are either making me align or making me
come apart
and i think the alignment i really do
think the alignment is i think alignment
is the right way of conceptualizing it
because i think if you say things that
are
as true as you can say them let's say
then they come up
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where thoughts
come from we don't know how far down
into your substructure the thoughts
emerge we don't know what processes of
physiological alignment are necessary
for you to speak from the core of your
being we don't understand any of that we
don't even conceptualize that but i
believe that you can feel that and i
learned some of that from reading carl
rogers by the way who's a great
clinician
because he talked about mental health in
part as the coherence between the
the
the spiritual or the or the abstract and
the physical that the two things were
aligned and and there's a lot of idea of
alignment in in psychoanalytic and
clinical thinking
but anyways i decided that i would start
practicing not saying things that would
make me weak and what happened was that
i had to stop saying almost everything
that i was saying i would say 95 of it
as a hell of a shock to wake up and i
mean this was over a few months but it's
a hell of a shock to wake up and realize
that you're mostly dead wood
it's a shock
you know and you might think well do you
really want all of that to burn off it's
like well there's nothing left but a
little husk five percent of you it's
like well if that five percent is
solid
then maybe that's exactly what you want
to have happen make a damn schedule and
stick to it okay so what's the rule with
the schedule
it's not a bloody prison
that's the first thing that people do
wrong they say well i don't like to have
follow a schedule it's like well what
kind of schedule are you setting up well
i should i have to do this then i have
to do this then i have to do this you
know and then i just go play video games
because who wants to do all these things
that i have to do it's like wrong
set the damn schedule up
so that you have the day you want
that's the trick it's like okay i've got
tomorrow if i was going to set it up so
it was the best possible day i could
have
practically speaking
what would it look like
well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that than at the beginning of the
day right because that's a stupid day if
you have a bunch of those in a row you
just dig you know you dig yourself a
hole and then you bury yourself in it's
like sorry that's just not a good
strategy it's a bad strategy so maybe 20
of your day has to be responsibility and
obligation or maybe it's more than that
depending on how far behind you are but
even that you can you can ask yourself
okay well i've got these
responsibilities i have to schedule the
damn things in
what's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward and you can ask yourself that
just like you'd negotiate with someone
who is working for you it's like okay
you got to work tomorrow
okay so i want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
going to do for me
that makes it likely that i'll work for
you well you could ask yourself that you
know so maybe you do an hour of
responsibility and then you play a video
game for 15 minutes i don't know
whatever turns your crank man but you
know you have to negotiate with yourself
and not tyrannize yourself
like you're negotiating with someone
that you care for that you would like to
be productive and have a good life and
and that's how you make the schedule
it's like and then you look at the day
and you think well if i had that day
that'd be good
great you know and you you're useless
and horrible so you'll probably only hit
it with about 70 accuracy but that beats
the hell out of zero
right and if you hit it even with 50
accuracy another rule is well aim for 51
the next week or 50 and a half percent
for god's sake or because
you're you're going to hit that position
where things start to loop back
positively and spiral you upward
and so
so that's one way that you can work on
your conscientiousness plan a life you'd
like to have
and and you do that partly by
referring to social norms that's more or
less rescuing your father from the belly
of the whale but the way other way you
do that is by having a little
conversation with yourself about
as if you don't really know who you are
because you know what you're like you
won't do what you're told you won't do
what you tell yourself to do you must
have noticed that it's like you're a bad
employee and a worse boss and both of
those work
you know for you you don't know what you
want to do and then when you tell
yourself what to do you don't do it
anyways you should fire yourself and
find someone else to be but but you know
what my point is is that you have to
understand that you're not your own
servant so to speak you're someone that
you have to negotiate with and that's
and you're someone that you want to
present the opportunity of having a good
life to and that's hard for people
because they don't like themselves very
much
so you know they're always like cracking
the whip and then procrastinating and
cracking the whip and then
procrastinating and it's like god it's
so boring and such a pathetic way of
spending your time you'll discover a
little bit more about your potential as
you discover who you are especially the
darker parts of yourself
because then you discover your potential
for mayhem there's some real utility in
that
you know a discovery that you're
dangerous it's such a useful discovery
it's actually something that strengthens
you because
the first thing
that a realization like that can in fact
produce is
the ambition to incorporate that danger
into a higher order personality that
dangerousness into a higher order
personality and that can make you
implacable
i can make you someone who can say no
when you need to say no
you know that can make you someone who
won't avoid necessary conflict and so
that's
as unbelievably useful if you want
another awesome jordan peterson video
check it out right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and i'll see you there